[Music]
well good afternoon from wherever you're
watching
this is our live program i'd like to
know
it airs every tuesday at 4
30 in the afternoon pacific time
and we have several interesting
questions today
before we have our prayer i do want to
announce where you can send your
questions you'll see it on the screen
the address is tv at some tv dot
org once again tv at some tv
dot org and you send us your questions
we'll do the research
and insofar as possible we will do
everything possible to answer your
questions amen
so i have with me uh pastor james
rafferty
uh and i'd like to ask pastor james to
have a word of prayer
to ask the lord to guide us and then
we'll go into our questions sounds good
let's pray father in heaven thank you
again for the interest
that people have in seeking a better
understanding of your word
thank you for this opportunity to answer
some of these questions and
we're always encouraged when we see
people who are eager
to learn and to grow we just pray that
your holy spirit will be our teacher
that you will guide us
in the answers that they'll be biblical
they'll be in harmony with the truth the
light
you've given us and that hearts who are
listening will be receptive to hear
and to respond to your word and we pray
all these things now and thank you in
jesus name amen amen
well the first question is actually an
informational item
that we're not going to answer on the
air because we do have a presentation
available from secrets unsealed
the question is please do you have a
book on the sermon
on how did we get the bible
you know that's a question that comes up
every so often and we certainly
do have a presentation on that
particular topic
it was done by gary jensen who for many
years was my associate pastor at fresno
central church
uh and the title of it is how did we get
the bible
so if you contact secrets unsealed dot
org
or some tv.org you'll be able to get
more information
on how to get that particular
presentation which was actually done
quite recently some very
valuable and interesting information so
we won't deal with that on the air
because we do have someone who
made a full presentation on that that
they can get from secrets unsealed i
might want to copy that
all right good deal uh you know because
there's the idea the roman catholic
church says you know we were the ones
that
gave the bible that's what my mom told
me we saved the bible for you guys
in other words the belief is that the
bible is is the servant of the church
and not the church the servant of the
bible
and so this is a very important
presentation and gary jensen
uh is a super well informed uh
individual i call him an encyclopedia on
legs
because he has information on many many
different things
now here's another question and maybe
pastor referee you can kick it off
okay do we need to keep the feast days
is observance of the feast days
necessary for salvation
or for any other reason as a practicing
christians
good good that's a great question it
isn't one that is new to us
it is one that has been raised in
centuries past
in fact it was a major issue in the
early church in the christian church
and it was debated in acts the book of
acts
at the jerusalem council and you can
find that in acts chapter 15.
and the reason why it was so hotly
debated was because
in the early christian church there were
thousands of converts
from judaism and but coupled with them
uh
as probation closed for the jewish
nation as a nation in 1834 with estonia
stephen
the gospel was then taken to all the
world and gentiles were included
so you have all these people coming into
christianity from the jewish background
the jewish faith and then you have
others coming in
that don't really have they're pagans
they're you know greeks they don't
really have any kind of judaism in their
background
and those two are are gathering together
in this one
faith of jesus christ and there was a
contention taking place because
all these jewish converts were of the
mindset
that these ceremonial laws that were all
fulfilled in christ and pointed to
christ
and actually had topology that really
helps us to understand the plan of
salvation
so they have a place uh were to be
observed they were continuing to be
observed
for example circumcision they believed
very strongly that uh everyone who
became a christian was also to be
circumcised
and so when they had this council you
know there was a hot debate paul of
course
uh even though he was a jew um by birth
really believed that the ceremonial laws
were fulfilled they were they were ended
in christ they pointed to christ they
pointed to the types and
were fulfilled and that they shouldn't
be forced on the gentiles
and and peter also stood with him in
that and finally a decision was made
that no
we weren't going to have the gentiles
follow these customs these ceremonial
laws
i say customs but they were laws that
got in and had given to him
but um he also very clearly and we can
talk about this a little bit more in
romans 14
he didn't um discourage jews
who were you know they were this was
tradition for them for for centuries
he didn't tell them that well if you did
did that you were wrong
he allowed everyone to be fully
persuaded in their own minds and if you
were a jew and that's the way you
believed and you had a hard time giving
it up that was no big deal
just don't force the gentiles to do as
you do don't
judge them or despise them for not doing
and gentiles don't judge the jews
because
unfortunately they're weak in the faith
in the sense that they have a hard time
just seeing this as being fulfilled
so paul was maneuvering this through the
churches and unfortunately there were
the judaizers
there were christian converts who were
strong in their jewish
traditions who had followed paul from
church to church
and they would actually undermine his
ministry
and tell people no you have to be
circumcised you have to keep the
ceremonial laws
and they uh developed a lot of there was
a lot of antagonism
that was developed towards paul minister
paul's ministry because of the judaizers
it seems like the book of acts would
indicate that the apostle paul
sometimes went to the feast and
celebrated the feasts
but probably not because he believed
that they still had
they were still binding but probably so
that he could meet his fellow
jews there and remember the heritage of
the jewish nation i think of that verse
as you talked to the jews i became a jew
to the greeks a greek to the
barbarian a barbarian and and he even
made the mistake which cut his ministry
short
of uh of of sanctifying himself for
a certain ceremony at the temple and
shaving his head and going down and
being identified as you know this
apostle is preaching christ
and then being taken by the romans and
eventually being in prison of course he
was let loose the first time
by nero but it did you know hinder his
ministry
and if you read in uh in the spirit of
prophecy we're told that it was not
god's will
that paul did what he did but
god saw his heart and his love for his
brethren's kinsmen according to the
flesh
whom we're told in romans chapter nine
he was willing to be accursed for christ
for their sake
that means anathema you know separated
from christ like moses
was willing and so he had this love for
his brethren and therefore he was
willing
he even had a gentile circumcised yeah
he would speak against their
circumcision but then he had timothy
circumcised because
he wanted to do everything he could to
reach his brethren
yep it wasn't a matter of principle to
him you know and there are
peacekeepers in the adventist church
today who say that
you have to keep the feasts or else
you're lost you know i have no
objections to them
uh celebrating the feasts if they want
to right you know
it's not a matter of life and death it's
not a matter of salvation or perdition
you know if they want to do it as a
commemoration
of the heritage of israel and a
commemoration of what christ has done
for us
you know it's a matter of conscience you
know some people have said that
colossians chapter two is biblical
evidence that the
festivals and the jewish system came to
an end
when jesus died on the cross do you have
anything more on
on colossians 7. i like colossians
chapter 2 let's just take a look there
because there's some
there's some thoughts here that are in
keeping with
some of the some of the points that were
made here in our discussion
and that is is that
the types the shadows the the
sanctuary service and all of the laws
connected with that
actually still have a place even now
today
uh you'll notice what paul says here in
colossians chapter two we'll just start
with verse 14
he says blotting out the handwriting of
ordinances which was
against us which was contrary to us he
took it out of the way out of the way
nailing it to the
to his cross and having spoiled
principalities and powers
made a show of them openly triumphing
over them in it
let no man therefore judge you in meat
or drink or respect of a holy day
or the new moon or of the sabbath days
which are
a shadow of things to come but the body
is of christ
which are a shadow of things to come so
we believe we're living in the great day
of atonement
the day of atonement as it was given to
the jews to the israelites to the
hebrews was a shadow of
what we're living in right now when you
look at the feasts
the spring feasts and the fall feasts
each of them has a place in the plan of
salvation
some of them were fulfilled when christ
came the first time others to be
fulfilled leading up to
and in the context of his second coming
and so they are a shadow they have a
place they they do help us they do
they do give us insight in fact we just
finished a whole sanctuary series with
doug batchelor amazing facts and the
group there
you know carlos and daniel and don
mcintosh
and others and it was a real blessing
because it was all about the sanctuary
and as we were going through that series
i think i was convicted at least
convicted or enlightened that you know i
think the sanctuary is probably in
every book of the bible old testament
new testament there's some sanctuary
symbolism there yeah so we can't just
throw this out you know
it has a place the book of hebrews is
filled with sanctuary language
and all of these ceremonies etc but like
you said pastor
um it's it's a shame when we start
putting them
on a level that god never intended them
to be put on especially in the new
testament
right that's what the judaizers were
doing in paul's day and that's what some
people unfortunately are doing today
whenever you have a shadow you have a
reality that projects the shadow
right so the old testament was the
shadow but people were supposed to look
forward
to that which was projecting the shadow
usually you have the object in the
shadow in this case you have the shadow
that directs people's minds to the
reality that projects the shadow
so you know once once the sun is
directly overhead
the shadow disappears it sure does
doesn't it so when jesus comes
the shadows disappear there's no reason
to observe them uh
that's great i have a few quotations
here and these have to do directly with
the passover
okay but i think by in principle they
apply also to the other
festivals um these are from the study
notes that i wrote for the
anchor class on the hebrew festivals
we we did an entire week just on the
hebrew feasts
and ellen white wrote several
interesting statements about the
passover i can just read a few of them
it was christ's desire to leave to his
disciples an ordinance this is the
lord's supper
that would do for them the very thing
they needed
that would serve to disentangle them
from the rights and ceremonies
which they had hitherto engaged in as
essential
and which the reception of the gospel
made no longer of
any force so clear to continue these
rights
would be an insult to jehovah
wow you know i was thinking about that
statement
um when you were talking about i have no
problem with people who want to keep the
passover and keep the ceremonies but
at the same time that's a supplement or
an addition to but if they're doing it
in place of in other words right
in place of what the reality is then it
would i think it would be an insult
i think ellen white is dealing here with
people who who think that they're still
in force yes
because she clearly says
in which the reception of the gospel
made no longer of any force
yes these people want to force everyone
to celebrate the feasts
you know if it's optional it's just you
know for example and i don't know if i
should mention the name but i will
because i heard him say it
richard davidson of the seminary old
testament scholar you know he
i think he now lives in loma linda but
you know he has a passover celebration
with his family every year
and you know it's a beautiful he
described the ceremony how they do it
you know with a special bread and
everything
you know it's just a beautiful reminder
of what jesus did with his disciples in
the upper room
but to say that it's absolutely
obligatory right that's a different
story
maybe i can read just one or two more
oh there's so many of them here this
patriarchs and prophets page 539 when
the savior yielded up his life on
calvary
the significance of the passover ceased
and the ordinance of the lord's supper
was instituted as a memorial of the same
event
of which the passover had been a type
and then she talks about people in the
early church who
tried to enforce the feasts she wrote in
acts of apostles 189
the jews had always prided themselves
upon their divinely appointed services
and many of those who had been converted
to the faith of christ
still felt that god had once clearly
outlined the hebrew manner of worship
it was improbable that he would ever
authorize a change in any of its
specifications that's what you were
mentioning
they insisted that the jewish laws and
ceremonies should be
incorporated into the rights of the
christian religion
they were slow to discern that all the
sacrificial offerings
had but prefigured the death of the son
of god in which
type met anti-type and after which the
rights
and ceremonies of the mosaic
dispensation
were no longer binding so clear
i mean so clear there's no way i want it
it's absolutely clear the bible is clear
and you know acts 15 is clear romans 14
is clear everywhere paul went you know
he dealt with this especially in the
book of galatians
and then you have the spirit of prophecy
to you know to help us to understand it
even
better so right it's crystal clear yeah
i believe so
okay now let's go to the next question
does the close of probation
close first for seventh-day adventist
then for the whole world
i have come across people who teach that
probation closes
first for sdas and then for the rest of
the world
kindly address this one it is uh
something i've come across too and uh a
lot of it is based on first timothy
chapter four verse 17.
and first timothy 4 17 says first
timothy first peter 4 17. thank you
first peter 4 17 says
uh i i can't i can't remember the
reference but hopefully let me know
i think i can read let's go ahead and
read it yeah first peter time has come
the judgments begin the house of god and
if it first begins at us
what shall be the end of those that obey
not the gospel of god
and this text seems to indicate that
judgment begins at the house of god
meaning or being interpreted to mean
that the time has come for the judgment
to begin at adventists
right and advocates are going to get
judged first and then the rest of the
world is going to get judged
but that's not really what the text is
saying right and if you read great
controversy
um she takes this text and gives it its
proper application
right you can see it in the context of
the verse because it says
if judgment begins at us what shall be
the end of those who don't even obey the
gospel of god right so those are people
who don't even profess right so judgment
begins with
everyone who professes faith in jesus
christ whether they're adventists or
methodists or catholics or presbyterians
whoever they are right judgment begins
with those who profess
and afterwards that is after the close
close of probation during the thousand
years you have that judgment for the
wicked the judgment for the lost
now there is a statement in the spirit
of prophecy that goes something like
this
the time of god's destructive judgments
is a time of mercy for those who have
not
heard the truth while the door is shut
for those who've heard the truth and
turned away from it
his hand of mercy is open still for
those who've already heard it and out of
that statement
they try to suggest you see judgment
begins with
adventists and if they don't respond
then their probation closes then it goes
to you know the rest of the world
other churches etc shepherds rod were
the first ones that i
encountered that really brought this in
you know it's really
interesting about shepherd's rod when i
was in oregon i was
there just in you know for a few years
and i was working with a pastor
who had a member a sabbath school
teacher in his church
that he was questioning and he just
wanted some advice for me some counsel
for me
and i said what is he teaching and he
said well he's teaching this
and i said well he's a shepherd rod and
he said no no no he's he's
he's a sabbath school teaches a leader
in the church whatever i said no he's a
shepherd's rod let's talk to him
so we went and talked to him and sure
enough he was a shepherd's rod
yeah and they come into the church they
come in the adventist church and they
start teaching this and you think this
is adventism and then
on the side they bring members out of
the church that's what they're trying to
do
and the method they use is they arrive
and they join a sabbath school class
first of all
and then they start making comments and
people say wow these people really know
about bible prophecy
and then they invite people to come to
their home to study
and then the rest is history you know i
pastored a church in torrington wyoming
which is in southeastern wyoming
right next to the nebraska border and
when i first arrived at that church i
noticed that the front door had a peep
hole
in it okay so i said to the head elder
who had been a member there since time
immemorial
i said what's with the peephole he says
well
you know what happened is that the
shepherd's rods would always come
and they would cause problems in the
church so what we would do
is in the morning we would have a deacon
that would look to the people when he
saw
a member in good and regular standing he
would unlock the door and let them in
when he saw one of the shepherds rods
which he had already identified
they kept the door locked so
you know that is a distinctive teaching
of the shepherd's rods
uh just if i could add one thing here in
first timothy chapter three
uh we have a confirmation of what you
mentioned about
the idea that the house of god includes
everyone who has ever professed the name
of christ
it tells us and by the way paul paul is
writing here
to christians in the first century so
notice uh what he says but if i am
delayed
i write so that you may know how you
ought to conduct yourself
in the house of god which is the church
of the living god the pillar and ground
of the truth okay
so what is according to the bible what
is the house of god verse was that
that's verse 15 of first timothy chapter
three
so so what is the house of god the house
of god is a church
including the church to which the
apostle paul is referring to here which
is the apostolic church
right so i love this because a lot of
times when we pluck a verse out of its
context
right and we then we have freedom to
interpret any way we want to
but if we look at it in its context
there's a fuller understanding that we
can get from the scriptures
you know that the exit jesus versus the
isa jesus of the text
and it's the same with the spirit of
prophecy so the lesser light helps us to
understand the greater light
and when you go to to great controversy
she quotes this verse
and she applies it exactly the way we're
applying it right yep i don't have the
reference before me but i know exactly
how she applies that yeah it's probably
in the chapter on the investigative
judgment
yes okay um you know and the idea is
that adventists are going to be sealed
first
and then the world leagues are going to
be sealed after that right
but i want to read from great
controversy 605
where ellen white writes the sabbath
will be the great test of loyalty
that would include god's people it would
for it is the point of truth especially
controverted
when the final test final test
shall be brought to bear upon men then
the line of distinction will be drawn
between those who serve god and those
who serve him not
while the observance of the false
sabbath in compliance with the law of
the state so this is when the sunday law
is enforced
contrary to the fourth commandment will
be in a vowel of allegiance to a power
that is in opposition to god the keeping
of the true sabbath
in obedience to god's law is an evidence
of loyalty to the creator
while one class by accepting the sign of
submission to earthly powers
receive the mark of the beast the other
choosing the token of allegiance to
divine authority
receive the seal of god so it's not a
case that god's faithful
adventists are sealed and then they go
out to proclaim the loud cry
and then there's a ceiling of
unbelievers that's not in harmony with
the spirit of prophecy teaches
yeah and that's the argument that's been
brought to me it's this idea
that we as adventists already know the
sabbath truth so
that's not a test for us and what i say
to that is well
knowing the sabbath truth and being
tested on the pain of not being able to
buy or sell and death
right two completely different things
you see evidence right now that know the
sabbath truth but they're not keeping
the sabbath
so to speak so we have to be tested even
though we know this truth we have to be
tested just like
all the rest of the world has to be
tested and what's really interesting is
we're told
very clearly that when the test comes
the majority of god's
adventist people today will forsake the
truth but
every place that is made vacant by
apostasy will be filled by those coming
into the church so in that context
isaiah chapter four is really clear
there you know seven men taking hold of
one man
in that context those who remain in zion
you know ezekiel chapter nine those who
romanians in jerusalem are going to be
sealed
right and the people that remain in
jerusalem are going to be those who are
faithful the minority plus
everyone that's coming in from the world
all of them together go through this
testing time
right but it's not until they actually
test it to the fullest extent
that they are sealed and once they're
sealed probation closes a short time
afterwards right just before we
we uh enter in the time of trouble jake
was the great time of trouble we
received the seal of god so
very clear very very clear sequence
okay um i think we pretty much answered
that question i might just mention one
thing
um here we have a book written by
alan barnes uh it's published actually
by um
white horse media steve wahlberg's
ministry
and it deals with this specific issue
okay uh sleuthing
it's called sleuthing the close of
probation
does heaven's door shut early for
seventh-day adventists
and it's an excellent little book it's
an easy read i read it uh pretty quickly
and i think it provides irrefutable
evidence
that probation does not close for
adventists before it closes generally
for all christians in the world okay so
you can get this from either from white
horse media uh or from secrets unsealed
whichever super okay we have time maybe
for one more
uh and uh you know this is one where
it's just a technicality
okay uh basically it says the first king
of the medes and persians was darius
and not cyrus of course we know that uh
ellen white says that darius died two
years after the conquest of babylon
so he continues saying thus ellen white
says in prophet prophets and kings
pages 5 56 and 557 that cyrus
was darius general who took babylon in
bc so the chronology is in 539
darius is the king and cyrus is the
general
of the armies okay thus cyrus ruled for
two years
uh
for two years and died at the age of 64.
by the way i checked
i checked how i'm supposed to pronounce
the word yeah and
uh it says uh when you google it that
both darius and darius are acceptable
oh great so i've always pronounced it
darius
anyway it's one of those where either or
all right
so thus darius ruled for two years and
died at the age of 64.
and then he puts daniel 5 31 and he puts
okay because he's saying 539 538 537
two years but the problem is
we don't know whether the median
persians counted the accession year
gotcha as a full year right it might
have been the first full year right
so so the idea here is you know if we
if we do from the year 537
then we would go back 70 years and it
would take us to the year 607 not 605
okay which we have traditionally
believed in okay uh you know it's just a
technical thing it's not a major issue
it would be if it was the 70 weeks right
the beginning of the 70 weeks
because that impacts so many other dates
it does but in this particular case
whether it was
uh you know from 607 to
to 537 or whatever it doesn't really
make any difference
uh the the fact is that israel remained
in captivity for a period of 70 years
at least that's the way i i see it yeah
i agree
yep so and he seemed to have a really
good attitude about this he says so what
do you think please read smile
[Laughter]
he sends me zillions of questions oh
he's always
i have a pile of questions that's sent
by him oh and um
you know we appreciate those questions
and many of them are very
very good questions i mean you can tell
that this person really studies
yes and really does research and is
sincere
in asking the questions so i like that
good attitude good spirit
something you really want to you know um
get into it praise the lord
some people send us loaded questions
yeah but and we try and answer those too
anyway with a loaded answer
[Laughter]
anyway well time is just about up i want
to remind you
that you can send us your questions you
see it on the screen tv
some tv.org and we will do everything
possible to answer your questions here
on a live program i'd like to know
every tuesday 4 30 in the afternoon
pacific time god bless you thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you
in our next program
[Music]
you